the gyro can experience to be just like
art just like music yes we're talking
about like do you like it or not write
music to you it might be the greatest
song of all time to Jamie he's like yeah
I can take it or leave it
yeah yeah and then you can have a car
you can have an argument about it which
is really sweet but no one's ever write
the bottom out yeah it's all love Motley
Crue you love mom and crew it's not it's
not this is anything wrong and by the
example but if you if you're [ __ ] at
home by yourself don't that that's art
like why was that judge hey I'd do that
with Whitesnake all the [ __ ] the
story before but a dude sent me in a
white snake cassette and I can't use
that it's in the office because uh I had
a girlfriend that made me throw it away
after I got in a car accident I had a
Whitesnake cassette in my car oh right
why'd she did because she thought of
jazz dude you she's really gonna tell me
what to do oh yeah she was older than me
okay and she she's packing up all my
stuff cuz my car was broken you know got
I got t-boned and as I'm grabbing all my
stuff she's like leave that I gonna
leave what she's like leave the
Whitesnake it's like you got to get over
that music it's like yeah it's terrible
music she was in like the Pixies that
kind of [ __ ] oh yeah just it back then I
loved I loved them too but I also loved
Whitesnake there's a thing that people
do though where they only like things
that make them appear smart or
interesting and there's like it's like a
hustle like you tell people you're
really an Indian food and you really you
might really be but there's also a thing
you're doing like you're you're that
person that's only into the cool stuff
but like them that [ __ ] Whitesnake
song is badass that here yeah yeah yeah
that's it's awesome they only had a few
they were like really good they had that
song is [ __ ] banging to this day is
this love that's a sexy video that was
good videos it's like one of my favorite
videos it's like the coolest even though
it was 80s and it was like hyper 80s
it's one of the few videos to me in my
mind that is that had a style that was
that kind of approaches timeless
really yeah in a way it's good as a
sweetness sincere the sincerity of it I
mean that video is sexy with Tawny
Kitaen and and and like her moving like
around the bed whatever it was classy it
was it was like sexy was very adult kind
of like watch it [ __ ] I have it but she
looks amazing and and I love him just
leaning on the wall like he's like mr.
cool guy it's it's done in such a
sincere way but it's just on the right
side of me still thinking that it's
[ __ ] great it's great art direction
it's promoting ridiculous interactions
yeah it was promote promoting a
ridiculous relationship just [ __ ]
talk what is all this drama I mean that
[ __ ] his hair he's very serious about
what he's singing he's like a
better-looking Luke from General
Hospital
remember when Luke and Laura yes that's
it that guy it's like a better look in
Luke that's so hilarious hair is
preposterous I know everybody's hair is
just like off the job I'm a Janu had a
friend that just had hair like that like
hey let's go let's go hit the gym he's
like hey man
you want to go go he's gotta go get some
a gallon of hair spray that [ __ ] I mean
primped out that's just I ran back then
that's that's white hair bro yeah you
have the solution to that yeah yeah your
hair you just it's fantastic you don't
have to do anything yeah exactly yeah
yeah yeah it's a totally lazy chaos it's
lazy
yeah it's chaos but at the same time
like right but there's no work involved
in I know it's a beautiful chaos Oh as
opposed to like yes no you got one of
them picks and your spray and picks and
spring oh yeah get his hair that big oh
I know there's a lot of work involved
there that's a [ __ ] ton of hairspray as
a lady offset it's just to keep yeah I
like checking symmetry I mean they the
guitar the band they like Whitesnake the
band wants some it was like it was the
supergroup
hard rock like like it or metal I guess
you can kind of it kind of bleeds into
that like classic metal there's been a
few of those super groups I didn't freak
me out man I'm like get off the car
that's what are you doing in the car
ladies it's like she doesn't she just
doesn't care she's rude she's on
cartwheels wild the cuffs in serious
that's what I mean man he's really
serious about what he's singing about
look and he's got three synth players in
a row by the way yeah look at that yeah
what is that mean that's correct kind of
hardcore I wish we could play this
because it's so wonderful I do love the
idea I mean let the hair color
combination in the car I mean
[Applause]